hi everybody welcome to Wired's first
Google+ Hangout live on air my name is
Adam and I'm the space and physics
reporter here at the wired offices in
San Francisco and today we've got our
aerospace reporter Jason Park he's going
to be talking to CEO and founder of
SpaceX Elon Musk
so Jason I think the bunch Adam sorry
it's mobility everybody and Heidi lon
it's one of the I guess the first
questions that we had was talking about
some of the delays and challenges of
getting this launch happening perhaps
you could tell us a little bit about
what's been happening the last week what
some of the testing and simulation work
that's being done and getting ready for
this watch sure so I mean we've spent a
great deal of time testing the hardware
and software associated with the rocket
and spacecraft and I could go on for a
long time talking about the details of
that but the biggest difference between
the last flight which weren't quite well
and this one is the docking system so we
we have an all new docking systems
haven't tested before and that's going
to go and acquire the space station to
block on to the space station and a plot
an approach vector and maneuver itself
over to to dock with the space station
and this it's a robotic spacecraft
that's that's operating under its own
intelligence it poses various points and
asks for authority to proceed but it's
really going under its own control with
the vast majority of the plane that's
one of the things that's intrigued me
about space flight in recent years you
know we all look back to the Apollo era
and even before that and there was
always this romantic notion of a test
pilot with a steady hand the nerves of
steel commanding a spacecraft and you
know even the first docking in space was
largely with a test pilot on board
nowadays it seems to be about software
engineers debugging lines of code is
that one of the new challenges is you
know that we're sort of taking the human
element directly out of it but there's
still that I guess the human involvement
in creating the software that's allowing
this to happen robotically yeah I mean
it's exactly this this the intelligence
that sort of moved to the autopilot
system and and Freya I mean even in the
days of Apollo they still had quite a
bit of computer assistance for that day
beautiful for that that era but
computers were you know vastly more
primitive then you know today I mean
your iPhone has more or Android phone
has more computing power than the entire
Apollo program just kind of hard to
imagine but now that we have so much
computing power available to us sort of
make sense to make use of it and and and
you know it and it just alleviate the
need to have someone onboard the
spacecraft maneuvering it into position
as a software guy yourself do you think
that this drive towards you know
software driven spacecraft and the
automation everything does it take any
sort of the romanticism out of space
travel that it's not sort of a pilot
sitting in a command seat so to speak or
is it a fair place to be since it seems
that software people seem to be funding
space these days so why not have
software and control I don't know I
think software engineers all the fighter
pilots of the new generation do you see
that it like killing you why you should
agree with I'm not disagreeing that's
for sure do you see that you know the
fact that there are so many software
people getting into it as far as you
know people that made the money in the
software industry whether it's yourself
Paul Allen these types and then now
funding private space endeavors is that
making even more of a push or was you
know the obvious natural progression
anyway is to to no longer need a test
pilot in let's see yeah I mean it's
I mean I think it's certainly a lot
safer and so it's a lot better for you
no loss of life to have it be computer
control well I should point out you know
when we do fly astronauts there will be
a manual override capability so you know
if if something unexpected goes wrong
then and it's not in the software to
correct it
that then it is helpful to have a human
in the loop and and so we will have a
joystick and you know you will be
actually able to control it when when
when there are people on board but in
the initial test phase I think it's
really great that were able to do it in
an automated basis because there's we're
not risking loss of life and and I think
I think that that's a great thing with
that risk after the meeting last week
with NASA you and some of the NASA folks
mentioned you know put emphasis on the
fact that this is a test that this isn't
an actual mission is that part of just
covering yourself or is that a real key
it's just it's not an operational
mission you know right now we will be
delivering a half a ton of cargo to the
space station and bringing stuff back
but it's going to be but kind of the
it's going to be stuff like food and
consumables that is valuable once it
reaches the space station but it's it's
not doesn't cost that much if it's lost
on route and but it is explicitly kind
of in the in beta mode you know so it is
in kind of a test phase so you know it's
soon as though we're asserting that
success is highly likely in fact we're
saying that there's a very good chance
the mission does not succeed that is the
nature of a test it is is that you know
is it really mine the public out there
that this is testing that we feel like
we've become so accustomed to space
missions just started going up going
down you know in the next day it happens
again but we haven't really had that
mindset of flight test in space for
quite a long time it seems is that part
of that goals room
I'm people that's where we're at again
yeah I think it is important to remind
people that this isn't this is a sort of
a new rocket and spacecraft the docking
system is it's being tested for the
first time and whenever you're trying
swing for the first time there's a good
chance it doesn't work and I said that's
why I really wouldn't want to explicitly
remind people that this this lot that
could go wrong on this mission but but
if something does go wrong we'll fix it
and we'll bake back at it on a
subsequent mission and I think we'll be
able to fly at least one or two times
more to Space Station this year do you
feel that there's more pressure on on
SpaceX because it's a private enterprise
and because there's so much buzz being
generated there's you know Gemini 8 the
first time that two spacecraft docked in
space everything didn't go well and it
sort of became a footnote in history do
you think the same thing if things don't
go perfectly
next week is it possible that it'll be a
footnote and like you say there's more
missions coming up that you'll be able
to engage in fix everything yeah I mean
I think I think if something just go
wrong it's it you know we'll sort it out
and we'll be back at it with such good
mission probably the summer and then
another flight at the end of the year so
and and I'm pretty okay I'm a highly
confident that at least one of those
missions will make it all the way to the
space station so this should be like
there should be no no doubt whatsoever
about our results continue we will
continue and we'll get it done can you
talk a little bit about some of the
simulations and maybe some of the
failure type work that was done a
testing with NASA and that sort of a
thing is it are these simulations where
NASA throws you a bunch of curveballs
and see how the people in Hawthorne
react or is it really a joint work where
you test possible failures it's it's a
very joint and very very interactive I
mean they're really a huge number of
tests going on and also Sabrina's there
are unit tests on subsystems that are
going on and then there are integrated
system tests which which we call sort of
we call them full hardware in the loop
simulations and that's where we've got
all of the electronics all the avionics
essentially of
the spacecraft out on a bench and then
we we feed the sensors information as
though it's in space so it's kind of
like a brain-in-a-vat
it actually thinks it's doing the
mission and it's receiving feedback as
though it's in space and we're providing
it some we're providing it the physics
feedback so when the thruster fires
we're feeding it what what physics is is
would or should deliver and so it really
thinks it went duck to the space station
and and then if something goes wrong we
stop it and we can assess what what the
issue is and and sort it out and then we
also of course have to interact with
NASA because one of the things one of
the bits of hardware that's in the loop
is the space station so we do these
integrated simulations with NASA and
NASA verifies that we were able to do
effectively a virtual docking with the
space station and if there's any issue
then we work together to iron it out
what would have been some of the
illuminating things in you know in
recent weeks that cause people to you
know some of these delays like this
latest delay was it just really some
minor details or was there any kind of a
big thing that popped up in these
simulations no there wasn't any any big
thing and how many there's a bunch of
minor things that in to give you sense
of what constitutes a minor thing you
know these are things that are
significantly less than a 1% risk of
mission mission abort
so because this we really care about the
mission completing so nothing we found
in the recent months has has been
related to an actual failure of the
spacecraft of you know in a major way
but it's what's inner to happen is it's
been too sensitive to issues and has
aborted when it shouldn't have aborted
so essentially dragon got scared and ran
away when it shouldn't have
so if then we said okay well that means
we've been too conservative in the rules
for avoiding a mission and we need to go
in and alleviate some of those
constraints then we also need to make
sure that when dragon reverts to backup
systems there's good dragons dragons
triple redundant meaning it's got an a B
and C string any one of those three
strings can operate the vehicle so you
can actually like if you have to cure a
gun you could put a bullet through any
two systems on the vehicle and it can
still it could still complete this
mission and we're going to make sure
that the logic associated with that
works does it in fact go to the B string
if a string fails does it properly
detect a failure and if you have
multiple failures in multiple areas of
different types then does the system
still behave as it should and how many
simulations have has you done with NASA
in the last few months or is it ongoing
I mean certainly dozens of simulations
with NASA and hundreds within SpaceX
okay looking at the bigger picture of
what SpaceX is trying to accomplish
obviously much of the talk is about
reducing the cost of delivering payloads
into orbit is that what you see is sort
of the main goal reducing that cost of
putting a pound into low-earth orbit was
that the biggest challenge you set out
to solve in the beginning or were these
just steps along the way to a bigger end
game well I mean the reason I started
SpaceX was because I think we needed to
develop the technology necessary to make
life multiplanetary and with Mars being
the the only realistic option for
creating another planet we essentially
creating a a base with a self-sustaining
civilization so that's really what's
basics has been on about the last 10
years since I started which is to keep
advancing the state of the art of rocket
technology
and one of the metrics is how much does
it cost to go to space that that's one
of the most fundamental metrics of
course a reliability is also important
and and achieving it and being able to
create a rocket that's big enough to get
to Mars is extremely important so we've
made steady progress in all those arenas
and I'm increasingly confident that if
we continue on this trajectory that we
will develop the technology necessary to
take people to Mars so I want to touch
on the Mars thing in a bit but I guess
in the progression to get there has the
the work that SpaceX has been doing to
reduce those costs to to drive the
business forward is it more of a
business proposition on how to create a
more efficient business or has there
been as much technology to develop and
that sort of a thing have you seen it
more as a company that's had to develop
a new business idea or new technologies
or do they go hand-in-hand it's it's I
mean it's it's it's mostly about new
technologies I mean there's a business
element to it as well of course because
you cannot you cannot abstract economics
from technology completely because if if
the economics don't work then a logical
adoption is impossible so what can you
can you outline what some of those
technologies when you started SpaceX did
you have something in mind that you said
to yourself well this is something I
definitely have to be able to fix well I
basically said I definitely have to
build to fix rocket technology we need
much better rocket technology
I mean if you think about it in 69 we
were able to go to the moon and then
with the Space Shuttle you could only go
to low-earth orbit and then Space
Shuttle retired last year so the United
States came and send people to low-earth
orbit now so I mean clearly that
trajectory is a downward one and and and
not a run a good situation at all so it
needs to be reversed and and and
dramatically so but isn't that I guess
the the rocket technology is there to do
it it was more of a economic or a
political thing when you say to advance
a rocket technology you're gonna
separate the economics from any given
technology yeah
if economics ever tech knowledge
bad then the technology is bad that's
all there is to it it is not there's no
such thing as technology that is good
abstracting from you know completely
abstract from economics good do you see
the competition down the road for
whether it's delivering things to the
space station or to low-earth orbit is
the competition to develop that
technology or do these think the
companies like orbital sciences or
Boeing or UNITA like Launch Alliance are
these competitors right now or do you
think that detect the technology that
you'll be developing will take you steps
beyond them so that there won't even be
a real concern anymore well honestly I
don't think that there's any any other
than any rockets in the world that are
seriously competitive with what SpaceX
developing except potentially what the
Chinese are doing long term but if you
know it I think I think we have the best
rocket technology in the world and it's
getting better faster I mean a blasty of
innovation I think is increasing so you
know when we go up and compete on the
world market against the Russians
Europeans Chinese or domestically Boeing
and Lockheed with the sole exception of
Defense Department business where they
have a sole source contract that I think
is completely outrageous
it's accept whether we're going Lockheed
are protected by egregious contract
SpaceX wins the competition I'm curious
as chief designer for SpaceX I assume
you've enjoyed learning a lot about
rocket design and space vehicles in
orbital mechanics and this sort of a
thing is there something that sort of
stands out in your your education of the
past decade or 15 years in the space
industry that's really stuck out is
something that you've enjoyed more than
and then was sort of a surprise or
whole packet there's two different
things I think I've certainly enjoyed I
mean it's really fun to see rocket
launch but those are just really epic
and even see rocket engines tested on
the ground and huge structures created I
mean that just the epic nature of it
didn't just have you know big and
powerful thing starts it's like wow you
just don't see that in everyday life so
that's really cool
as far as surprised well I mean a
protein surprised by a lot of things I
didn't really know anything about
rockets well not much about rocketry
before starting SpaceX but there's no I
would say there's any any huge surprises
just a lot of maybe a lot of small
medium ones when you know you see didn't
know a whole lot about rockets before
starting SpaceX when did you get this
idea were you a kid who played with
model rockets or was this idea that you
wanted to go to space and make life
multiplanetary that's something you got
later in life without something you've
thought about is younger yeah um well I
did actually I mean I did blow up
Turner's kid in South Africa I mean
stuff we didn't have STS Rockets I
actually mixed moon rocket propellant
grain and everything and know something
about rockets earlier then uh yeah yeah
I mean so it's not that hard to make a
solid rocket although I mean the hardest
thing was getting the saltpeter which
had come up with some some excuse to get
it from a chemist because you can just
buy it but the reason for SpaceX is
because I think you know when I was in
college I thought well what are the
things that are most going to affect the
future of humanity you know what are the
one of the important problems one of the
most important problems that need to be
solved in my opinion and and and that
one where one could apply technology to
solve them and and the three things that
I came up with with the internet
sustainable energy and space exploration
particularly making life multiplanetary
and
you know in terms of the internet
obviously it's like the like humanity
acquiring a collective nervous system
you know whereas previously we were more
like like a Hydra like a collection of
cells that communicated by diffusion
with the advent of the Internet it was
like we suddenly got a nervous system
you know in terms of the human
collective it's it's a hugely impactful
thing and then sustainable energy I
think it's the single biggest problem
the 21st century we either solve that or
we're screwed
I mean obviously it's totally logical
and then making life multiplanetary is
important because the last 4 billion
years life has been confined to earth at
life as we know it please and I think
there's there's some a chance that
something terrible will happen on earth
and the light of consciousness is
extinguished and I think we should apply
some of our resources to prevent that
from occurring I'm not saying it should
be a huge number but perhaps you know a
quarter of a percent of the GDP or
something like that and in order for
that to occur we need the technology
developed to make that possible so what
we're doing at SpaceX is trying to help
make progress in that direction with the
trip to Mars where do you see the
biggest challenges right now do you
think the technology exists right now -
I mean obviously we put robots on Mars
is it that the ability to get a human
there to make the trip to sustain life
there where is the biggest roadblock to
getting a person on Mars right now
well the biggest we don't there's not
currently a rocket big enough to take
people to Mars and but even if there was
the issue is not one of having some
super expensive program that is able to
do a flags and footprints mission to
Mars like we did with the moon that that
would set a new high altitude record and
would be interesting but would not be
all that impactful in the future of
humanity I think what what really
matters is developing
that's capable of transporting huge
numbers of people and cargo to Mars such
that it can become a self-sustaining
civilization and getting the cost of a
trip to Mars while moving to Mars I
think down to something that kind of a
middle class person in America can
afford and if we can do that then I
think it will occur there will be a sort
of naturally self-sustaining reaction
and life will become multiplyin Terry
just as in the early days of the United
States the best really kind of how the
United States was formed
you know if the cost of a trip to
America got down to something that you
know a relatively local class person in
into England could afford and so enough
people chose to make that journey to
form beginnings the United States with
some of the new companies that keep
springing up I mean just this week we
had Planetary Resources announced their
plans do you see all these coming
together as part of that the fabric
that's needed to create a trip to Mars
that can be affordable I mean do you
think asteroid mining is going to be a
key part for instance to get that
ability to open up space travel a longer
distance
I think asteroid mining is something
that frankly is only relevant in the
context of of a serious effort to settle
Mars I don't think it's relevant in an
earth context so all these companies
that are springing up whether it's
SpaceX or Planetary Resources or some of
these others basics quite different from
Planetary Resources no I realize that
but do you see that all these companies
are sort of all putting pieces into the
puzzle that will allow this trip to Mars
that will allow multiplanetary life or
do you see that SpaceX is taking its own
direct path and you know you'll pretty
much be able to do it on your own
I think we'll be able to do it on our
own or at least I want to make sure that
we can do it on our own it's not as
though necessarily one - but if we have
to
if if that's the path that that is
required then then we must be able to
execute that path and I like so I think
mining asteroids is is it is you know
it's not necessary for for creating a
self-sustaining civilization on Mars but
it could potentially be helpful you know
as a refused my required do you see the
first trips to Mars being one way or a
round-trip I think I think round trip
yeah I think it's the one way thing I
think is unnecessary because seeing in
order to like say the thing that's
important is is that we were able to
transport ultimately millions people
millions of tons of cargo to Mars and in
order to do that in order to be able to
make that feasible you really need the
spacecraft to come back so whether the
people choose to come back or not is
beside the point
you need spaceship to come back so it
just it's just like in the early days of
like in the early day you need reusable
spacecraft at the return um and in I can
open when England was exception colonies
in America like they needed the ships to
return if the ships were just one way I
mean they'd run out of wood in England
so what does that challenge then again
bring bring home this idea that we
needed a new rocket needs to be
developed spacecraft all that yeah we
definitely need to develop a new
generation of rockets so so I don't for
example think that we'll be sending
people to Mars using our Falcon line of
rockets I think it'll be with the next
generation of rockets beyond that but
Falcon will be helpful as a technology
technological stepping-stone are some of
those ideas being put to paper or put to
with a CAD system yeah yes I believe I
have a design that will close and when
do you think there will be any kind of
information being put out by SpaceX that
explains some of its Mars projects is
that something is going to happen in the
few years in a decade yeah I mean I
think I think part no well I think well
people probably talk about it maybe end
of the year old maybe maybe sometime
next year yeah let's see yeah I I think
right now we need to focus on docking
with the space station and not get
distracted from that important task but
but I think probably talked about it in
a year here or so okay well you know I
really appreciate the time and good luck
with the docking mission set to go off
next week and we look forward to hearing
about Mars in the future all right
sounds good thanks Chris clear with you
thank you all right thanks guys